that's like minimum requirement you have  to have a car  um I've also realized that I want  someone that has like some sort of  creative or like job and entertainment  like I have you have to be very  ambitious because I am very ambitious I  want to be able to like you know we'll  spend our days or whatever separately  and then at the end of the night I want  us to be able to come together and talk  about all of the exciting things that  happen in each of our lives right like  okay this other guy was like well I'm  not rich I'm a regular guy and I was  like that's fine but like I'm not a  regular girl like I'm I'm not so like if  you're if you are gonna date me like  either you have to be able to handle  that or you yourself also wants to not  be like regular